In his memoir, My Dark Places, James Ellroy writes about how he was haunted by the memory of his mother. She was murdered in 1958 when he was 10. 35 years later, he tried to track down her murderer. His mother was last seen in El Monte, California with a man Ellroy calls "the swarthy man" and with a blond woman. Ellroy hired a private investigator. He also tried to scare up some leads by having two papers do stories about the murder and having the TV shows, Day One and Unsolved Mysteries do segments. All of them but Day One gave out a phone number for people to call with tips and leads.
在詹姆斯·艾洛伊的回忆录《我的黑暗之地》中，他记述了自己是如何被母亲的记忆所困扰的。母亲在他10岁那年，即1958年被谋杀。35年后，他试图追查凶手。母亲最后一次露面是在加州的埃尔蒙特，当时她和一个艾洛伊称为“黑肤男人”的男子及一名金发女子在一起。艾洛伊雇佣了一名私家侦探。他还通过两家报纸报道谋杀案，以及《第一天》和《未解之谜》等电视节目制作相关专题来搜集线索。除了《第一天》之外，所有媒体都留下了电话号码，供民众拨打提供线索。
As the phone calls came in, Ellroy found it he wasn't the only one who was haunted. This is from his memoir.
随着电话不断打来，艾洛伊发现被困扰的不止他一个人。以下内容摘自他的回忆录。
"A man from Oklahoma City, Oklahoma, called. He said the swarthy man looked like a guy named Bob Soans. Bob murdered his wife, Shari, and committed suicide. It was late '58. The crime occurred in North Hollywood. A man from Centralia, Washington called. He said his father was the swarthy man. His father was 6'6 and weighed 240 pounds." I should say this does not match the description of the real swarthy man. "His father carried a gun and lots of ammunition."
“一位来自俄克拉荷马州俄克拉荷马城的男子打来电话。他说那个黑肤男人看起来像个叫鲍勃·索恩斯的人。鲍勃谋杀了他的妻子莎莉，随后自杀身亡。那是58年年底的事。犯罪发生在北好莱坞。一位来自华盛顿州森特勒利亚的男子打来电话。他说他父亲就是那个黑肤男人。他父亲身高6英尺6英寸，体重240磅。”我得说明一下，这与那个真实的黑肤男人的描述不符。“他父亲带着一把枪和大量的弹药。”
A man from Savage, Minnesota, called. He said the swarthy man looked like his father. His father lived in El Monte back then. His father was abusive. His father served prison time. His father was a gambler and a skirt chaser. A man from Rochester, New York, called. He said his grandfather was the swarthy man. Gramps lived in a nursing home. The man supplied the address and phone number.
一位来自明尼苏达州萨维奇的男子打来电话。他说那个黑肤男人看起来像他父亲。他父亲当时住在埃尔蒙特。他父亲有虐待倾向，还坐过牢。他父亲是个赌徒，也是个好色之徒。一位来自纽约州罗切斯特的男子打来电话。他说他爷爷就是那个黑肤男人。爷爷住在一家养老院。那个人提供了地址和电话号码。
A woman from Sacramento, California, called. She said the swarthy man looked like a local doctor. The doctor lived with his mother. The doctor hated women. The doctor was a vegetarian. A woman from Lakeport, California, called. She said the swarthy man looked like her ex-husband. Her ex chased women. She didn't know where he was now.
一位来自加州萨克拉门托的女子打来电话。她说那个黑肤男人看起来像当地的一位医生。那位医生和母亲住在一起。医生仇视女性。医生是个素食者。一位来自加州莱克波特的女子打来电话。她说那个黑肤男人看起来像她的前夫。她的前夫是个好色之徒。她不知道他现在在哪里。
A woman from Covina, California, called. She said her sister was raped and strangled in El Monte. It happened in 1992. A woman from Paso Robles, California, called. She said the swarthy man looked familiar. She met a man like that in 1957. He wanted sex. She said no. He said he wanted to kill her. He lived in Alhambra then.
一位来自加州科维纳的女子打来电话。她说她的姐妹在埃尔蒙特被强奸并勒死。那是1992年发生的事。一位来自加州帕索罗布尔斯的女子打来电话。她说那个黑肤男人看着眼熟。她在1957年见过这样的男人。他想发生关系。她说不。他说他想杀了她。他当时住在阿罕布拉。
A woman from Benwood, West Virginia, called. She said a man stalked her and her brother in Los Angeles. She was six years old. The man had dark hair and good teeth. He drove a truck. He took off her clothes, fondled her and kissed her. She saw him on a TV game show several years later. It might have been The Groucho Marx Show. "
一位来自西弗吉尼亚州本伍德的女子打来电话。她说一个男人曾在洛杉矶跟踪她和她的兄弟。她当时六岁。那个男人留着黑发，牙齿很好。他开着一辆卡车。他脱掉她的衣服，抚摸她并亲吻她。几年后，她在电视游戏节目中看到了他。那可能是《格劳乔·马克斯秀》。
Ellroy's list of callers goes on for pages.
艾洛伊的通话名单长达好几页。
Why don't more adults celebrate Halloween? Why don't adults go to horror movies in the same numbers that teenagers do? I believe it's because so many of us, we're already haunted, haunted by people who've harmed us, haunted by people we fear, haunted by people we've harmed, haunted by people who've gone.
为什么更多的成年人不庆祝万圣节？为什么看恐怖片的成年人不像青少年那么多？我相信这是因为我们当中的许多人已经备受困扰——被伤害过我们的人困扰，被我们恐惧的人困扰，被我们伤害过的人困扰，被那些已经离去的人困扰。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose some theme. We bring you a variety of stories on that theme. Today's program, Haunted. Haunted not by ghosts or phantoms, but by other people, by reality. Act One, Hearing Voices. A girl gets a tape recorder for Christmas, loves to record her parents, but only when they fight. Her parents die. The tapes survive.
好了，这里是芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共电台联合制作的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目主题是“困扰”。并非受鬼魂或幻象的困扰，而是受他人、受现实的困扰。第一幕，听到声音。一个女孩在圣诞节得到了一台录音机，喜欢录下父母的声音，但只在他们吵架时录。她的父母去世了，录音带留了下来。
Act Two, why a Jewish family in New York embraces a Holocaust survivor as a member of their family without much evidence that he really is. Act Three, Ashes. David Sedaris says, I love you, to his mother, and she tells him that she's going to pretend that she did not hear him say it. The story of how he and his family reacted when she got lung cancer. Act Four, Ghost Story. Heather Woodbury demonstrates that there is no rock and roll heaven. Stay with us.
第二幕，为什么纽约一个犹太家庭在几乎没有证据证明他是大屠杀幸存者的情况下，就接纳他为家庭成员。第三幕，灰烬。大卫·塞达里斯对母亲说“我爱你”，她却告诉他，她要假装没听到这句话。这是一个关于他和家人在母亲患肺癌后作何反应的故事。第四幕，鬼故事。希瑟·伍德伯里证明了根本没有摇滚天堂。请继续收听。
Act One, Hearing Voices. Lynnette Nyman is a reporter for Alabama Public Radio and uses a tape recorder in her regular job. But this story is about recordings she made as a kid-- 9, 10, 11, 12 years old.
第一幕，听到声音。琳内特·尼曼是阿拉巴马公共电台的一名记者，工作中经常使用录音机。但这个故事是关于她小时候——9岁、10岁、11岁、12岁时录下的录音。
The tapes come from my taping my family. I taped my family. But see, I didn't tape the happy moments. I taped all the trying moments.
这些磁带源于我录下家人的声音。我录下了家人的声音。但你看，我录的不是那些快乐的瞬间。我录下的全是那些令人抓狂的时刻。
Why?
为什么？
Maybe my own intrigue? I don't know.
也许是我自己的好奇心？我不知道。
Well, I didn't do it.
嗯，我没做。
Well, I didn't either.
嗯，我也没做。
Well, I guess you did if you lifted the door up and got it in, didn't you? The person that makes the mess cleans it, don't they?
好吧，我想如果你把门抬起来放进去，那就是你做的，对吧？制造混乱的人负责打扫，难道不是吗？
I don't clean your goddamn oven.
我才不打扫你那该死的烤箱。
Hey, I didn't make the mess.
嘿，又不是我弄乱的。
Hell no, you haven't cooked for days.
见鬼，你已经好几天没做饭了。
Why did you just say that?
你为什么刚才要那么说？
There's old motor mouth going.
快看，那个大嘴巴又开始了。
I'm not a motor mouth, but I want to know why you made that statement.
我不是大嘴巴，但我就是想知道你为什么那么说。
I'm trying to get this place in condition for you to paint.
我正试着把这地方整理好，让你刷漆。
Why don't you shut up, or else he's not going to do it at all.
你为什么不闭嘴，否则他根本不会去做了。
At one point in the recordings, somebody is painting? Is that what's happening?
在录音的某个时候，有人在刷漆吗？那是怎么回事？
Right.
是的。
And do you remember this? Do you remember this actually happening?
你还记得这个吗？你记得这事真的发生过吗？
I do. I do.
记得，我记得。
And where are we in the house? What room are we in?
我们在房子的什么位置？我们在哪个房间？
You're actually in the kitchen. We're in the kitchen. And see, this is where my mom has finally caught on to this whole thing and my taping. And this was when I fell into her trap. And she had said to me, "Lynnette, go get the tape recorder."
其实在厨房。我们在厨房。你看，正是在这时，我妈妈终于识破了这一切，识破了我的录音行为。这发生在我落入她圈套的时候。她对我说了：“琳内特，去把录音机拿来。”
You mean she'd start a fight and then she'd say, "Go get the tape recorder"?
你是说她会先挑起争吵，然后再说“去把录音机拿来”？
Yes.
是的。
What do you think was going on? I mean do you think that she's just getting into a little tiff with him, and she's like, well, "I'll show him. Not only am I going to have this fight, but I'm going to embarrass him, too, on tape."
你觉得当时发生了什么？我是说，你觉得她只是和他发生了一点小口角，然后心想，“我得给他点颜色看看。我不仅要跟他吵，还要把这一切录下来让他出丑”？
Well, the funny thing though is that if she were going to do that, why didn't she ever play it for anybody? She never did. And maybe she did think that. Maybe she thought, OK, yeah. Like she said on the tape, she said "Well, I've got witnesses here." And witnesses for what?
嗯，有趣的是，如果她真要那样做，为什么从来不放给任何人听呢？她从来没放过。也许她确实是那样想的。也许她想，好吧，是的。就像她在磁带里说的那样，她说“我这儿有证人呢”。证人又是什么意思？
Oh, oh now start a fight.
哦，哦，现在开始吵架了。
See, I've got a lot of things that I've got witnesses hear what you said. Dial the wrong number on the paramedics if I collapse, is that what you plan to do?
看，我有好多东西有证人听见了你说的话。如果我晕倒了，你打算拨错急救人员的电话号码吗？
You want to argue?
你想吵架吗？
No, that wasn't a funny statement, that one. I'd never thought that one up.
不，那句话可不好笑，那一句。我以前从没想过那个。
I thought it was pretty funny.
我觉得挺好笑的。
That's your father for your mom, see?
那是你父亲对你妈妈说的，你看？
Is this what their regular, everyday relationship was like? Or was this different than the way they were normally?
他们的日常关系一直就是这样吗？还是说这和他们平时的样子不同？
I think it was like it was everyday life.
我觉得这就是他们的日常生活。
Oh really?
哦，真的吗？
As far as I remember. Yeah, yeah. It was really these highs and lows.
据我记忆所及。是的，是的。确实是那些高潮和低谷。
Dad could have had this done this morning while he got up. Why didn't you get this taken care of this morning?
爸爸本可以在早起的时候就把这事做完。你为什么今天早上没把它处理好？
I had company.
我有客人。
Who?
谁？
Gracie.
格雷西。
Why would that have held you back?
为什么那会耽误你？
Rams are playing in Chicago and you made me miss the game right now.
公羊队正在芝加哥打比赛，而你让我错过了现在的比赛。
What if the Angels are playing at the Angels' stadium? They're going to play every week and every day of your life. That's what you've been saying for the last 27 years, Bill. Our home has to have maintenance and repair done to it.
如果天使队在天使体育场比赛呢？他们余生每天每周都会打比赛。比尔，这正是你过去27年来一直说的。我们的家必须进行维护和修理。
I was wondering if when you hear this, if she sounds harsh to you?
我很好奇，当你听到这些时，她听起来对你很严厉吗？
Yeah.
是的。
She does?
真的吗？
She does, yeah. She sounds really harsh, and it kind of hurts because she talked to me like that too.
确实，是的。她听起来真的很严厉，这有点伤人，因为她也是这样对我说话的。
Yeah?
是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
OK, let me play you a little snippet here.
好吧，让我为你播放一小段。
OK.
好的。
You're sick, you know that, don't you?
你病了，你知道吧？
Hey, nobody could put up with all your yelling and screaming.
嘿，没人能忍受你那没完没了的叫嚷和尖叫。
I'm one of the sweetest girls that ever walked.
我是这世上最甜美的女孩之一。
Ever walked. I'll bet you again if I died and you had a guy in here, he'd leave within a week.
最甜美。我敢打赌，如果我死了，你再找个男人进来，他一周内就会离开。
How much do you want to bet?
你想赌多少？
Start barking at him.
开始对他大吼大叫吧。
How much you want to bet?
你想赌多少？
Now, you were laughing?
现在，你在笑吗？
Yeah, it's funny.
是的，这挺好笑的。
What are you hearing?
你听到了什么？
I guess my father's humor. To me, it's funny.
我猜是我父亲的幽默感。对我来说，这很有趣。
Which part is the joke? He's saying nobody can put up with your screaming. Which is the joke part?
哪部分是笑话？他说没人能忍受你的尖叫。哪部分是笑话呢？
My father was just going along. And she was the one in control, and she always was in control. And his response was to just joke.
我父亲只是顺着她说。她是那个掌权的人，她一直掌控着局面，而他的回应就是开玩笑。
You know I ain't as young as I used to be. Crawlin' around-- I injured my knee.
你知道我不像以前那么年轻了。爬来爬去——我伤了膝盖。
What knee did you hurt?
你伤了哪个膝盖？
My wee knee.
我的小膝盖（wee knee）。
What? Your what? Your what, Bill?
什么？你的什么？你的什么，比尔？
My knee. Wee knee.
我的膝盖。小膝盖。
You are sick, aren't you? Who do you talk to? Your little girls?
你病了，不是吗？你跟谁说话呢？跟你的小女孩们？
I jammed my knee into that thing.
我把膝盖撞到那个东西上了。
Is that the way you talk to your little girls?
这就是你和你的小女孩们说话的方式吗？
No.
不是。
Now, after he died-- he died first, right?
现在，在他去世之后——是他先去世的，对吧？
Yeah, she kept the tapes after he died. Actually, I found them. I remembered, and I found them, and I listened to them. And then I was the only one at home then, and I played them for her. I brought it out and put the tapes in and we listened. And we'd sit around the kitchen table just the two of us, and she'd cry, and I'd cry.
是的，他去世后她保留了这些磁带。实际上是我发现了它们。我记起来了，找到了它们，然后听了。那时候家里只有我一个人，我就放给她听。我把磁带拿出来放进机器，我们一起听。我们俩围坐在厨房桌子旁，她哭了，我也哭了。
And what do you think she was hearing when she would hear these tapes, often of her berating him and badgering him?
当你听到这些磁带时，通常是她训斥和纠缠他的声音，你觉得她在听什么？
I think she heard her love. That's what I think.
我觉得她听到了她的爱。这就是我的想法。
Wow.
哇。
And if anything, if she didn't hear her love, then she was just hearing him. And that was enough, and that was everything to her. I mean she was dedicated to him for 35 years. When I look at some of her letters that she wrote to me while I was overseas for a couple years, it was all about, gosh, if only your father were here, I wouldn't be so lonely. And I think that those tapes were a reminder.
即便她没有听到她的爱，那她听到的也只是他。这对她来说这就足够了，这就是一切。我的意思是，她对他忠诚了35年。当我看到她在我出国那几年写给我的信时，全都是关于，天哪，要是你爸爸在这里就好了，我就不会这么孤单了。我觉得那些磁带是一种提醒。
Do you like your home, Bill?
你喜欢你的家吗，比尔？
No.
不喜欢。
Not at all?
一点也不？
Yeah, a little bit. [INAUDIBLE]
嗯，有一点点。[听不清]
You want to admire my home or run me down like a bald swine.
你是想赞美我的家，还是想把我贬低得像只秃猪一样。
You know I admire your home. I admire you.
你知道我很欣赏你的家。我很欣赏你。
Then don't put me down, Bill.
那别贬低我，比尔。
Do you think that she ever listened to the tapes and thought, God, I should have been sweeter to him. I should have been sweeter?
你认为她有没有听过磁带，然后心想，天哪，我本该对他更温柔一点。我本该更温柔的？
No, no, no. I don't think so. I don't think so. I think it was totally normal and natural for her to be like that. And she never saw anything she ever did as being wrong, ever, never for a moment.
不，不，不。我不这么认为。我不觉得。我认为她那样做是完全正常且自然的。她从来没有认为自己做过的事情是错的，从来没有，哪怕一秒钟都没有。
Rembember that, I didn't do it.
记住那个，我没做。
Why you didn't do it? You didn't do it.
你为什么没做？你没做。
No, I didn't do it.
不，我没做。
You come out here and say, where's that lazy son of a bitch at? Well, I've been working my goddamn ass off. That's where I've been.
你出来说，那个懒惰的混蛋在哪儿？好吧，我一直在极其努力地工作。我就在那儿。
Yeah, I'm sure your ass looks worked off.
是的，我相信你的屁股看起来确实像累坏了。
One of the things that's so odd about these tapes is that your parents actually discuss a lot what'll happen after they die, and who will get what.
这些磁带最奇怪的一点是，你的父母实际上讨论了很多关于他们死后会发生什么，谁会得到什么。
I know, and I was sitting there going, yeah, yeah, yeah.
我知道，我当时坐在那儿心想，是啊，是啊，是啊。
You guys will get your will changed.
你们会更改遗嘱的。
You're changing your will right away?
你要立刻修改遗嘱吗？
Yeah. I don't want to leave it to anybody. I might leave it to the Good Shepherd.
是的。我不想留给任何人。我可能会留给善良的牧羊人。
Yeah, your household furniture too?
是的，连同你的家庭家具？
No.
不。
All I want is the TV.
我只想要那台电视。
She only wants the TV.
她只想要电视。
I want the TV  in the dining room and the framed camel out there.
我想要餐厅里的电视和外面那个装裱好的骆驼画。
Who is it who says-- when they're talking about that, somebody pipes up, "I'll get the TV. I get the house."
是谁——当他们讨论这个时，有人插嘴说，“我得到电视。我得到房子。”
My sister says, "I get the television." And I say, "I get the house."
我妹妹说，“我得到电视。”我说，“我得到房子。”
How'd it work out?
结果如何？
Well, in my tapes, everything came true.
嗯，在我的磁带里，一切都成真了。
Really?
真的吗？
For the most part.
大部分情况是这样。
List all the things that came true?
列出所有成真的事情？
My sister got the television. The house actually went into the trust and was put up for sale. And my brother was cut out of the will.
我妹妹得到了电视。房子实际上进了信托基金，并挂牌出售了。而我兄弟被剔除了遗嘱。
Wait, is that actually in the tape, that somebody says, you're going to get cut out of the will?
等等，磁带里真的有提到，有人说，你会从遗嘱中被剔除吗？
Yeah, my mother jokes on the tape that she wouldn't remarry, and she didn't remarry. She had a boyfriend later on.
是的，我母亲在磁带里开玩笑说她不会再婚，她确实没再婚。她后来有个男朋友。
She actually says that, "I have a boyfriend," right? She says, "I'm not going to remarry. I'll just see somebody."
她确实说了，“我有男朋友”，对吧？她说，“我不会再婚。我只是会和某人见面。”
Right.
是的。
One's enough for me, baby. I'll never go through it again. They'll never have to worry. Mother might have a boyfriend to bring over there and see them, but I won't have a stepfather for them to look at.
宝贝，对我来说一个就够了。我再也不会经历那一切了。他们永远不必担心。母亲可能会带个男朋友回来让他们见见，但我不会找个继父让他们看着。
[INAUDIBLE] Or you just throw a drink in his face. Son of a bitch.
[听不清]或者你就直接把酒泼在他脸上。混蛋。
Pardon me? Who'd you just cuss? I can't hear you?
你说什么？你刚才骂谁？我听不见？
SOB he said.
他说的是混蛋（SOB）。
Who'd you cuss?
你骂谁？
It's you obviously. You bring it home.
显然是你。是你把这带回家的。
He's getting jealous.
他开始嫉妒了。
You wouldn't be jealous after you're gone, would you?
你走后你就不会嫉妒了，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
No, because I'd be in the right hands beside Jesus.
不，因为我会回到耶稣身边的怀抱里。
Let me ask you about how you all are acting, how the kids are acting in these recordings. I'm going to play you another little snippet.
让我问问你们的表现，孩子们在这些录音中表现如何。我再给你放一小段。
That's your father for your mom, see.
那是你父亲对你妈妈说的，你看。
Oh, you know damn well I'd run you all the way down to the police station.
哦，你明明很清楚我会把你一路赶到警察局。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
I'd throw you in the back of the new truck.
我会把你扔进新卡车的后座。
Wouldn't it be funny if they hit a bump? She'd fall out and we'd just laugh.
如果他们撞上颠簸不很有趣吗？她会掉出来，我们只会笑。
Get there and say, where did you go? Mom is crying.
到那儿然后说，你去哪儿了？妈妈在哭。
So on the tapes, you guys are laughing. The kids are laughing. And then at one point, you say, "Mom's crying." What is happening?
所以在磁带上，你们在笑。孩子们在笑。然后有一次，你说，“妈妈在哭。”发生了什么？
I think she was hurt. She finally felt some hurt there. And that's where I stop, and I think, oh gosh, I was just so stupid. And I was caught up in it too. And what shouldn't have been funny at all was funny to me then. And why? I don't know. And maybe it's just again, we're just coping We're just trying to get along.
我想她受伤了。她终于在那里感觉到了一些伤痛。就在我停下来的地方，我想，天哪，我真是太蠢了。我也卷入了其中。那时根本不该觉得好笑的事情，对我来说却很可笑。为什么？我不知道。也许这又一次说明，我们只是在应对。我们只是在努力相处。
Do you view yourself as haunted by this time and by these tapes?
你认为自己被这段时光和这些磁带困扰了吗？
Yeah, I guess I do. I feel like I can't get rid of them, and I totally want to be away from them completely. But my thought these last few days was that I thought to myself, well, OK, after I do this interview, this is it. I'm getting rid of these tapes. I'm going to free myself from these things forever. But you know I won't. They're going to go right back into the box.
是的，我想是的。我觉得我无法摆脱它们，而且我完全想彻底远离它们。但这几天我的想法是，我心想，好吧，好的，做完这个采访后，就是这样了。我要处理掉这些磁带。我要永远把自己从这些东西中解脱出来。但你知道我不会的。它们会直接放回盒子里。
Hearing these tapes, I've really thought a lot about what survives of a person. And we don't get to choose what survives of us. Do you think if your dad had a choice about the matter, if he would want you to still have these tapes?
听到这些磁带，我真的思考了很多关于一个人死后会留下什么的问题。我们无法选择我们死后会留下什么。你觉得如果你父亲有选择权，他会希望你仍然留着这些磁带吗？
I would say no. I would say he would say, get rid of them. He would say, life was pretty good. And sure there were rough moments, maybe quite a few of them, but overall, things have turned out pretty well. And he would say the tapes were-- no, not good to keep.
我会说不。我会说他会说，处理掉它们。他会说，生活相当不错。当然有艰难的时刻，也许还不少，但总的来说，事情结果还不错。他会说这些磁带——不，不适合保留。
Would you tape around the house? Would you ever tape in your personal life?
你会录下家里的声音吗？你会录下你的个人生活吗？
No.
不。
You don't have recordings or videotapes of you and your husband?
你没有你和你丈夫的录音或录像带？
No, absolutely not.
没有，绝对没有。
Because of this?
是因为这个吗？
I think so.
我想是的。
Lynnette Nyman in Alabama.
阿拉巴马州的琳内特·尼曼。
Act Two, this is the story of a boy who was thrown into the concentration camps when he was three, lost his parents. And although he survived the war, he was so young when it ended that he couldn't remember his parents and wasn't sure of his own last name. He was adopted by a Swiss family, raised in Switzerland. His family gave him a German name. He was haunted by the past. When he saw a picture of William Tell in school, he thought it was an SS officer shooting a little kid. The apple on the kid's head just made it extra cruel.
第二幕，这是一个男孩的故事，他在三岁时被扔进集中营，失去了父母。尽管他在战争中幸存下来，但战争结束时他年纪太小，以至于记不起父母，也不确定自己的姓氏。他被一个瑞士家庭收养，在瑞士长大。他的家人给了他一个德国名字。他被过去所困扰。当他在学校看到威廉·泰尔的画时，他以为那是党卫军军官在射杀一个小孩。孩子头上的苹果让这一幕显得格外残酷。
In his  40's, he started to search for clues about who we was. He thought his real name might be Binjamin Wilkomirski from Riga. Last year, he published a book about his search called Fragments. In New York, writer Blake Eskin and his mother got their hands on the book. It turns out that Wilkomirski is a pretty unusual name. All the Wilkomirskis seem to descend from one town in Lithuania called Wilkomir. Some Wilkomirskis came to America, changed their name to Wilbur, married into other names. Blake and his mother are Wilburs descended from Wilkomirskis.
40多岁时，他开始寻找关于自己身世的线索。他认为自己的真名可能是来自里加的本雅明·威尔科米尔斯基。去年，他出版了一本关于自己寻找身世的书，书名叫《碎片》。在纽约，作家布莱克·埃斯金和他的母亲拿到了这本书。威尔科米尔斯基这个名字相当不寻常。所有的威尔科米尔斯基似乎都源自立陶宛的一个叫威尔科米尔的小镇。一些威尔科米尔斯基人来到美国，改姓威尔伯，通过婚姻改姓其他名字。布莱克和他的母亲是威尔科米尔斯基家族的后裔，现姓威尔伯。
When Binjamin Wilkomirski came to the States on a speaking tour sponsored by the Holocaust Museum, they got together with him to figure out the past.
当本雅明·威尔科米尔斯基在由大屠杀纪念馆资助的巡回演讲中来到美国时，他们和他见了面，试图探究过去。
It's the Sunday afternoon before Rosh Hashanah, the holiday marking the Jewish new year, and my parents' apartment is full of Wilburs. It's mostly the Frum side of the family, the religious side. The men were yarmulkes, the women long sleeves.
那是赎罪日的前一个周日下午，那是标志着犹太新年的节日，我父母的公寓里挤满了威尔伯一家。大部分是弗鲁姆那边的亲戚，即信教的那一边。男人们戴着圆顶小帽，女人们穿着长袖。
Binjamin Wilkomirski arrived a half hour late with his wife and his handlers from the Holocaust Museum. He didn't look like a Wilbur to me, but then again, he didn't look like anyone I'd ever met before. He was wearing a yellow shirt. His light brown hair was styled into a curly, puffy Jewfro and he had extra-long sideburns that didn't quite meet at his chin.
本雅明·威尔科米尔斯基迟到了半小时，带着他的妻子和大屠杀纪念馆的工作人员。在我看来，他长得不像威尔伯家的人，但话又说回来，他看起来不像我以前见过的任何人。他穿着一件黄色的衬衫。他浅棕色的头发被烫成了卷曲蓬松的“犹太爆炸头”，鬓角很长，在下巴处还没完全连接起来。
The hairdo and the paisley scarf knotted around his neck tagged him as bohemian. He wreaked of stale cigarettes. There's a big turnout. Binjamin brought the Wilburs together in a way tradition and ritual have failed to do. The religious and secular sides of my family have very little contact. Bar Mitzvahs and weddings are too expensive to invite everyone. Funerals too sudden for everyone to drive or fly in. And the American style family reunion, with printed t-shirts and picnic coolers and tubs of macaroni salad, is simply unthinkable. But an audience with a Holocaust survivor who is both a family mystery and a minor celebrity is well worth the hassle of finding a parking spot in Manhattan on a Sunday afternoon.
那发型和颈部系着的佩斯利花纹围巾让他看起来像个波西米亚人。他身上有一股陈旧的香烟味。到场的人很多。本雅明以一种传统和仪式未能做到的方式将威尔伯一家聚集在一起。我家族中信教和世俗的两派很少往来。受洗礼和婚礼因为太贵，不会邀请所有人。葬礼又太突然，无法让每个人开车或坐飞机赶来。而那种印着T恤、备着冷藏箱和桶装通心粉沙拉的美式家庭团聚，根本是不可想象的。但是，与一位既是家庭谜团又是小名人的大屠杀幸存者见面，还是值得在周日下午为在曼哈顿找停车位而费一番周折的。
At first, nobody knew what to do. Binjamin seemed affable, but also tired and a bit bewildered. After everyone introduced themselves, a couple of Wilburs approached him. They were carrying Ziploc bags, and in the bags were copies of Binjmain's book. They asked him for autographs. I felt embarrassed and worried about what Binjamin thought of us. But he signed their books as he would for any stranger. My relatives thanked him and sealed the books back in the Ziploc bags. Things had started on the wrong foot.
起初，没人知道该怎么办。本雅明看起来随和，但也很疲惫，有点困惑。大家自我介绍后，几位威尔伯家的成员接近了他。他们提着密封袋，袋子里是本雅明的书。他们请他签名。我感到尴尬，担心本雅明会怎么看我们。但他像对待任何陌生人一样给他们的书签了名。我的亲戚们感谢他，并把书重新密封在袋子里。开局不利。
My mother decided to intervene. She sat Binjamin down next to my aunt Miriam. Miriam, who was wearing a smart purple suit and a lavender and white turban, is the matriarch of the orthodox wing of the family. She and her two brothers are the only living Wilburs who were born in Riga, where Binjamin thinks he came from. Miriam arrived in America in 1929, when she was 18 years old.
我母亲决定介入。她让本雅明坐在我姑妈米里亚姆旁边。米里亚姆穿着一套时髦的紫色西装，戴着薰衣草色和白色的头巾，她是家族正统派的女族长。她和她的两个兄弟是唯一健在的在里加出生的威尔伯人，本雅明认为他就是来自里加。米里亚姆18岁时，即1929年抵达美国。
This is after the war, my mother, two brothers and me. And that's my husband.
这是战后，我母亲、两个兄弟和我。这是我丈夫。
At a small folding table, Miriam flips the pages of her tattered photo album, a high school graduation gift from her teachers back in Riga. My mother and I are hoping that one of the photographs will jog Binjamin's memory like a mug shot. Binjamin's memory is patchy, but Miriam remembers the past, She is in her late 80's, old enough to remember the Jewish refugees who fled to Riga during the First World War.
在一张小折叠桌旁，米里亚姆翻动着她那破旧的照片集，那是她在里加读书时老师送的毕业礼物。我和母亲希望其中一张照片能像嫌犯照片一样唤起本雅明的记忆。本雅明的记忆支离破碎，但米里亚姆记得过去。她已经80多岁了，足够记得第一次世界大战期间逃往里加的犹太难民。
It was so awful. Somebody came and killed. The streets were filled with dead people. I remember. That's life. What can you do? All right, going back here. Oh, here is the picture with what they think is the Avram. This Avram is the uncle.
太可怕了。有人来了，杀了人。街上满是死人。我记得。这就是生活。你能做什么？好吧，回头看这里。哦，这是那张他们认为是阿夫拉姆的照片。这个阿夫拉姆是叔叔。
Avram, Miriam's uncle, was the only Wilkomirski brother who remained in Riga. He is the number one candidate for missing link between Binjamin and the Wilburs. Avram could be Binjamin's uncle, or maybe even his father. Miriam is pretty sure, however, that Avram had only one son. His picture is in the scrapbook. That boy would have been 10 years older than Binjamin.
阿夫拉姆，米里亚姆的叔叔，是唯一留在里加的威尔科米尔斯基兄弟。他是联系本雅明和威尔伯家的头号候选人。阿夫拉姆可能是本雅明的叔叔，甚至可能是他的父亲。然而，米里亚姆相当肯定，阿夫拉姆只有一个儿子。照片在剪贴簿里。那个男孩会比本雅明大10岁。
On the other hand, it's possible that the family in America might not have known about other children because it was difficult to communicate with Riga in the late '30's.
另一方面，也有可能美国的家人并不知道还有其他孩子，因为在30年代末与里加交流非常困难。
So who of your family finally remained in Riga during the war?
那么你们家谁最后在战争期间留在了里加？
During the war? Just Avram.
战争期间？只有阿夫拉姆。
Just and his family?
只是他和他的家人？
Avram's children, that's--
阿夫拉姆的孩子，那是——
Do you remember their names? No?
你记得他们的名字吗？不记得？
The more I learn about Binjamin, the less I believe we're related. Binjamin was separated from his family when he was two or three years old. He doesn't know exactly how old he was because he doesn't know when he was born, or where he was born, or even what his real name is. The only way he knows anything about who he is, is that on his way from Auschwitz to an orphanage after the war ended, a woman saw him and told him he was Binjamin Wilkomirski from Riga.
我对本雅明了解得越多，就越不相信我们有亲戚关系。本雅明在两三岁时就与家人分开了。他不知道自己具体多大，因为他不知道自己出生日期，也不知道出生在哪里，甚至不知道真名是什么。他了解自己身份的唯一途径是，战后他在从奥斯威辛去孤儿院的路上，一位妇女看到了他，告诉他他是里加的本雅明·威尔科米尔斯基。
Binjamin tells me that recently, when he visited Riga, he stood on the spot in the ghetto where he remembers the Nazis murdered his father. Or maybe it was his uncle. He's not sure. I believe Binjamin when he says he remembers, but part of me thinks he's been looking for the place where his memory happened for so long, and he's read so much about Riga, that he subconsciously willed himself into finding it. For that matter, I'm not fully convinced that half a century later, he can honestly remember what some lady told him his name was. Or if he does remember correctly, that she even knew his real name to begin with.
本雅明告诉我，最近当他访问里加时，他站在贫民窟里他记得纳粹杀害他父亲的地方。也许是他叔叔。他不确定。当本雅明说他记得时，我相信他，但我内心深处认为，他寻找这段记忆发生的地点太久了，而且读了太多关于里加的书，以至于他潜意识里希望自己找到它。就此而言，我并不完全相信半个世纪后，他能诚实地记住某位女士告诉他他的名字是什么。或者即使他记对了，那位女士当初甚至都不知道他的真名。
One of the ironies of this situation is that Binjamin has invested years of his life in finding out who he is, and he still doesn't know. But he has learned a lot about who we are. He knows all about the Wilkomirskis, where they lived and where they came from. Binjamin has found other Wilkomirskis in Poland and Lithuania. In a register from the Vilna ghetto, Binjamin found a Sonya Wilkomirski. He asks if we've ever heard of Sonya, if she's a relative. Miriam says no, firmly, but everyone else in the room is looking for a way to make the answer yes.
这种情况的讽刺之处在于，本雅明投入了多年的时间来寻找自己是谁，但他仍然不知道。但他确实了解了很多关于我们是谁的信息。他了解所有关于威尔科米尔斯基家族的信息，他们住在哪里，来自哪里。本雅明在波兰和立陶宛找到了其他威尔科米尔斯基人。在维尔纽斯贫民窟的登记册中，本雅明发现了一个索尼娅·威尔科米尔斯基。他问我们是否听说过索尼娅，她是不是亲戚。米里亚姆坚定地说了不，但房间里的其他人都在寻找让答案变成“是”的方法。
Maybe like a nickname? Sonya?
也许是像绰号之类的？索尼娅？
All through the afternoon, people keep saying Binjamin has the Wilbur face. They say he looks like Miriam's brother, Haymi, that he looks a little like my cousin Steven, that he looks like me. Everyone has their theory.
整个下午，人们不断说本雅明有威尔伯家的脸。他们说他看起来像米里亚姆的兄弟海米，看起来有点像我的表弟史蒂文，看起来像我。每个人都有自己的理论。
Among things one doesn't normally look at that I do is the shape of the nostrils.
我不常看的东西之一是鼻孔的形状。
That's my mother. She's an amateur sculptor.
那是我母亲。她是位业余雕塑家。
Because they're very distinctive. They're similar, but not that close. The overall look, yes. I do think there is a resemblance.
因为它们非常有特色。它们相似，但没有那么接近。总体的长相，是的。我确实认为有相似之处。
Sitting in my parents' living room, Binjamin seems oddly uninterested in what is potentially his long lost family. His attention to Miriam's photo album comes and goes, and he doesn't ask any questions about us. I'm not sure why he's so detached. It could be fatigue or shyness, or maybe his weariness of getting entangled with us. In the end, Binjamin tells me he's sure we're family, though he isn't too concerned about where he fits on the Wilbur family tree.
坐在我父母的客厅里，本雅明似乎对这潜在的失散多年的亲戚并不感兴趣。他对米里亚姆照片集的关注时有时无，他也没有问任何关于我们的问题。我不确定他为什么这么疏离。可能是疲惫、害羞，或者是厌倦了与我们纠缠不清。最后，本雅明告诉我，他确定我们是亲戚，尽管他并不太关心他在威尔伯家谱中的位置。
All the Wilkomirskis are somehow connected. I'm absolutely sure, but maybe you have to go far back. But you see, at the end, the humans feelings are much more important than to know how, are you related in the second or third or fourth generation back or so.
所有的威尔科米尔斯基人都是有某种联系的。我完全确定，但也许你必须追溯到很远以前。但你看，归根结底，人类的感情远比知道你们是在第二、第三还是第四代亲缘关系上重要得多。
After Binjamin and the Wilburs left my parents' house, there were five of us left-- me, my mother and father, my mother's cousin Susan and her husband. We talked about why so many Wilburs had showed up, and why they seemed so interested in Binjamin.
在本雅明和威尔伯一家离开我父母家后，只剩下我们五个人——我和我的父母，还有我母亲的表妹苏珊和她丈夫。我们谈论为什么有这么多威尔伯人出现，以及为什么他们似乎对本雅明这么感兴趣。
On one level, the Wilburs were seeking the same thing Binjamin was, a key to the past. For most American families, anything that happened before the boat landed is a blur. The Wilburs are an American invention, and Binjamin, if he is one of us, can show the Wilburs what we were before we got to Ellis Island. Susan flew in from Southern California just to meet Binjamin. She said that knowing he was a member of the family would give her, as she put it, "a sense of roots."
在某种程度上，威尔伯一家在寻找和本雅明一样的东西——一把开启过去的钥匙。对于大多数美国家庭来说，船靠岸之前发生的一切都是模糊的。威尔伯家族是一个美国的创造，而本雅明，如果他是我们的一员，就可以向威尔伯一家展示我们在到达埃利斯岛之前是什么样子。苏珊从南加州飞来就是为了见本雅明。她说，知道他是家庭的一员会给她一种，用她的话说，“归属感”。
One person who doesn't need a sense of roots is Miriam, with her memories of Riga, her religious rituals and her 35 great grandchildren. Perhaps that was why she seemed the most skeptical that Binjamin Wilkomirski was one of us.
一个人不需要归属感的是米里亚姆，她有着对里加的记忆，她的宗教仪式和她的35个曾孙。也许这就是为什么她看起来最怀疑本雅明·威尔科米尔斯基是否是我们的一员。
Blake Eskin's story of Binjamin Wilkomirski continues. Also a story from David Sedaris. That's all in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
布莱克·埃斯金关于本雅明·威尔科米尔斯基的故事还将继续。此外还有大卫·塞达里斯的故事。这一切都在一分钟后，来自国际公共电台，节目继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Haunted, not by the supernatural, but by other people and reality and the past. We're in the middle of Blake Eskin's account of a man who may be a long lost relative of his. Or it might not be.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的各种不同类型的故事。今天的节目，困扰，不是被超自然现象，而是被他人、现实和过去所困扰。我们正处于布莱克·埃斯金讲述的关于一个可能失散多年的亲戚的故事中间。或者可能不是。
The next day, Binjamin was the guest of honor at a $150 a plate luncheon at the Carlyle, a ritzy hotel on the Upper East side that John F. Kennedy used to use as a sex pad. The Holocaust Museum comped our family an entire table, and ten Wilburs showed up. This was a different bunch of Wilburs than at my parents house the day before. No orthodox Wilburs came. The food wasn't kosher enough. These Wilburs were on the assimilated end of the spectrum, people I know pretty well.
第二天，本雅明是卡莱尔酒店150美元一餐的午宴的嘉宾。卡莱尔酒店是上东区一家高档酒店，约翰·F·肯尼迪过去常把它当作性爱场所。大屠杀纪念馆为我们一家提供了一整桌餐位，十个威尔伯人到了场。这批威尔伯人与前一天在我父母家的人不同。没有正统派威尔伯人来。食物不够洁净。这些威尔伯人属于同化程度较高的一端，都是我很熟悉的人。
How are you doing, mom? Sorry.
你好吗，妈妈？抱歉。
I've got my mouth full I'll talk to you in a minute.
我嘴里塞满了东西，一会儿再和你聊。
I can't remember the last time everybody got together in Manhattan.
我不记得上次大家在曼哈顿聚会是什么时候了。
It was probably at your Bar Mitzvah or Deborah's Bat Mitzvah. Probably Deborah's Bat Mitzvah.
很可能是在你的受洗礼或黛博拉的受洗礼上。很可能是黛博拉的受洗礼。
There's a cocktail hour before lunch. Some of my relatives haven't even met Binjamin yet, but they're already willing to accept him into the family.
午餐前有鸡尾酒时间。我的一些亲戚甚至还没见过本雅明，但他们已经愿意接受他进入这个家庭了。
Whether or not he is related, it somehow seems immaterial. This is a contemporary, a cousin, let's say. I mean that's the way I feel about it.
不管他是否是亲戚，这似乎并不重要。这是一个同代人，一个表亲，我们可以这么说。这就是我的感受。
And if he's not a cousin, we make him a cousin.
如果他不是表亲，我们就让他成为表亲。
Everyone is willing to embrace Binjamin as a family member without any proof. And all of them are feeling a new-found closeness to the Holocaust. They all say, it could have been me. After an asparagus appetizer and a salmon entree, the MC of the luncheon, a major donor to the Holocaust Museum, gets up and introduces Binjamin. He doesn't need any proof either.
每个人都愿意毫无证据地接纳本雅明为家庭成员。他们都感到对大屠杀有一种新发现的亲近感。他们都说，那也可能是我。在芦笋开胃菜和鲑鱼主菜之后，午宴的主持人，大屠杀纪念馆的一位大捐赠人站起来介绍了本雅明。他也不需要任何证据。
It is my pleasure to welcome you today to today's very special luncheon. Before I continue, I'd like to acknowledge just a couple people in the room. Our author, Mr. Wilkomirski's family is all here, and they're sitting at table 11.
很高兴今天欢迎各位参加这个非常特别的午宴。在继续之前，我想请各位认识一下在座的几位嘉宾。我们的作家威尔科米尔斯基先生的家人全都在这里，他们坐在11号桌。
It bothers me that we are introduced as family without any qualification. I start to get upset. I won't fudge my family history for a lousy three-course lunch. But my mother calms me down.
我们被毫无保留地介绍为家人，这让我很不舒服。我开始感到不安。我不会为了糟糕的三道菜午餐而捏造家族史。但我母亲让我平静下来。
If it helps the Holocaust Museum to call us his newly discovered family, that's fine with me.
如果大屠杀纪念馆称我们为他新发现的家人对他们有帮助，我没意见。
So you don't feel like we need to get up and correct the record?
所以你不觉得我们需要站起来纠正记录？
Absolutely not. I think it's helpful to the museum and possibly to Binjamin to say his family is here and to tell a story that we discovered each other.
绝对不。我认为对博物馆来说，可能对本雅明来说，说他的家人在这里，并讲述一个我们发现彼此的故事是有帮助的。
Over the next week, we get to know Binjamin and his wife, Farina, a little better. My parents take them for a dim sum breakfast in Chinatown and a walk through lower Manhattan. Binjamin and Farina invite me to dinner. We have a good time. The hesitation and awkwardness of our first meeting is gone. After dinner, Farina goes to their room, and Binjamin and I sit down in the lobby of the Waldorf Astoria.
在接下来的一个星期里，我们更好地了解了本雅明和他的妻子法里纳。我父母带他们去唐人街吃了点心早餐，在曼哈顿下城散步。本雅明和法里纳邀请我共进晚餐。我们度过了一段美好的时光。第一次见面的犹豫和尴尬已经消失了。晚餐后，法里纳回房休息了，本雅明和我坐在华尔道夫酒店大堂里。
You've helped us learn a lot about our family. And I mean thank you for that.
你帮我们了解了很多关于我们家族的事。对此我表示感谢。
Because I am very happy that your reaction was so positive. And when I got the first letter by [UNINTELLIGIBLE], though you can't imagine how excited I was. I really was jumping from excitement.
因为你的反应如此积极，我感到非常高兴。当我收到第一封信时……你无法想象我有多兴奋。我真的激动得跳了起来。
I ask Binjamin if he has considered taking a DNA test with us to determine if we're really family. Binjamin says he's not interested. He says that if we're distant relatives, the test might not tell us anything. And then he tells me a story about the man he calls Father Yaakov.
我问本雅明是否考虑过和我们做个DNA检测来确定我们是否真的是一家人。本雅明说他没兴趣。他说如果我们是远亲，测试可能什么也测不出来。然后他给我讲了一个关于他称之为“雅科夫父亲”的人的故事。
A woman who saw Binjamin's picture on television called him up to say that he looked exactly like her nephew, who she thought had died in the Holocaust. She said the father of this boy had survived and was living in Israel. Binjamin called the man in Israel and discovered that they had some memories in common. They decided to take a DNA test. It took about four weeks for the test results to arrive.
一位在电视上看到本雅明照片的妇女打电话给他，说他长得和他侄子一模一样，她以为那个侄子死于大屠杀。她说这个男孩的父亲幸存下来，住在以色列。本雅明给以色列的那个人打了电话，发现他们有一些共同的记忆。他们决定做个DNA测试。测试结果花了大约四周时间才出来。
For me it was very strange. I realized suddenly that during all the last decades, I never thought that I had a father. I was always completely fixed on the idea that I must try to somehow recreate the picture of the moment in [UNINTELLIGIBLE] People told me, that's your mother. I was always thinking of that. And in a way, that blocked me completely. I never thought about a father.
对我来说这很奇怪。我突然意识到，在过去几十年的时间里，我从来没想过我有父亲。我总是完全执着于这样一个想法，我必须尝试以某种方式重新创造[听不清]中的时刻。人们告诉我，那是你母亲。我总是那样想。从某种程度上讲，这完全封锁了我。我从没想过父亲。
A week before the test results arrived, this man calls Binjamin.
在测试结果出来前一周，那个人给本雅明打了电话。
He said he has still a father's love toward his son. He could never live. He has still this to give. And I'm looking for somebody like a father. And he just offers to be for me like a father and even ready to accept that he will receive me at his home. So we went to his home, and we met his family.
他说他对自己儿子的父爱依然存在。他从未能够真正生活。他依然有这份感情要付出。而我正在寻找像父亲一样的人。他主动提出做我的父亲，甚至准备接受我去他家住。所以我们去了他家，见了他的家人。
The test results were negative. But Father Yaakov, a pious man in his 80's, helped Binjamin resolve something that had tormented him since the concentration camps.
测试结果是阴性。但雅科夫父亲，一位80多岁虔诚的人，帮助本雅明化解了自集中营以来一直折磨他的痛苦。
And so, half a year later, I called him. I talked to him on the telephone. And then I said I wished to come alone for half a week or a week to see you. You said you will always be ready to give me advice. And he said, "Of course you can come. My house is open."
于是，半年后，我打电话给他。我在电话里和他谈过。我说我希望能单独去见你半周或一周。你说你随时准备给我建议。他说，“当然可以来。我的大门永远向你敞开。”
As a boy in the camps, Binjamin had done something that led to the death of another boy, and he felt guilty. Yaakov told him he didn't have to.
作为一个在集中营里的男孩，本雅明做了导致另一个男孩死亡的事情，他为此感到内疚。雅科夫告诉他没必要这样。
In the moment when that happened, I was maybe four and a half or five years old. I had the feeling that I'm doing something that's not right. And I thought the real guilt and the responsibility starts in the moment when you're conscious of it. But he explained that the Holocaust says that a child cannot be responsible for that unless the child learned about the law. That was very important for my inner peace.
在那件事发生时，我可能只有四岁半或五岁。我感觉我做的事情是不对的。但我认为真正的内疚和责任是从你意识到它的那一刻开始的。但他解释说，大屠杀的教训是，除非孩子了解法律，否则孩子不应对此负责。这对我的内心平静非常重要。
Binjamin calls Father Yaakov every Friday morning, and they visit one another four or five times a year. Maybe we'll keep in touch with Binjamin too. I hope we do. Binjamin is haunted by his past and the uncertainty surrounding who he is in a way that my family can never be. But since he left, I feel more haunted by the present.
本雅明每个周五早上都会给雅科夫父亲打电话，他们每年互相探望四五次。也许我们也会和本雅明保持联系。我希望如此。本雅明以一种我家人永远无法体会的方式被他的过去和关于他是谁的不确定性所困扰。但自从他离开后，我感觉被现实困扰更多了。
I keep thinking about what might have become of me if my great grandmother hadn't left Riga when she did. If I had been born at all, I might have ended up as an orthodox Jew in Brooklyn, or an unemployed engineer in Tel Aviv, or a Moscow mafioso with a gold tooth.
我不断思考，如果我曾祖母当年离开里加时没那么做，我会变成什么样。如果我根本没出生，我可能会以布鲁克林的正统犹太人、特拉维夫的失业工程师或戴着金牙的莫斯科黑手党身份告终。
One of the luxuries of melting into the American mainstream is not having to think about where you came from, or what might have happened if you'd stayed there. You can ignore your past most of the time, but every once in a while, it comes back to haunt you.
融入美国主流社会的奢侈之一，就是不必考虑你来自何方，或者如果你留在那儿会发生什么。你大部分时间都可以无视你的过去，但偶尔，它会回来困扰你。
Blake Eskin first wrote about Binjamin Wilkomirski in The Forward. Wilkomirski's book is called Fragments. It's published by Shocken Books.
布莱克·埃斯金最初在《前进报》上撰写关于本雅明·威尔科米尔斯基的文章。威尔科米尔斯基的书名为《碎片》。由肖肯图书出版。
Act Three, Ashes. We can be haunted by others, or we can be haunted by the way that we behaved ourselves. This is a story of both kinds of haunting. Several years ago, three weeks before his sister Lisa's wedding, David Sedaris got a phone call from his mom back home in Raleigh, North Carolina. She had lung cancer. She was a lifelong, unrepentant smoker.
第三幕，灰烬。我们可能受他人困扰，也可能受我们自己的行为困扰。这是一个关于两种困扰的故事。几年前，在妹妹莉萨婚礼的三周前，大卫·塞达里斯接到了来自家乡北卡罗来纳州罗利市母亲的电话。她得了肺癌。她是一个终身、不知悔改的吸烟者。
My sister Amy was with me when my mother called. We passed the phone back and forth across my tiny New York kitchen, and then spent the rest of the evening lying in bed, trying to convince each other that our mother would get better, but never quite believing it. I'd heard of people who had survived cancer, but most of them claimed to get through it with the aid of whole grains and spiritual publications that encourage them to sit quietly in a lotus position. They envisioned their tumors and tried to reason with them.
母亲打电话来时，我妹妹艾米和我在一起。我们在我纽约狭小的厨房里轮流接电话，然后在床上躺了一整晚，试图说服对方母亲会好起来，但内心从未真正相信过。我听说过有人幸存过癌症，但他们大多数人声称是在全谷物和鼓励他们盘腿静坐的精神读物的帮助下挺过来的。他们构想自己的肿瘤并试图与它们理性沟通。
Our mother was not the type to greet the dawn or cook with oats and barley. She didn't reason. She threatened. And if that didn't work, she chose to ignore the problem. We couldn't picture her joining a support group or trotting through the mall in a warm-up suit. 62 years old, and none of us had ever seen her in a pair of slacks. I'm not certain why, but it seemed to me that a person needed a pair of pants in order to defeat cancer.
我们的母亲不是那种会迎接黎明或用燕麦和大麦做饭的人。她不沟通，她威胁。如果那不管用，她选择无视问题。我们无法想象她参加支持小组或穿着热身服在商场里走来走去。62岁了，我们谁都没见过她穿长裤。我不确定原因，但我觉得一个人需要穿裤子才能打败癌症。
Just as important, they needed a plan. They needed to accept the idea of a new and different future free of crowded ashtrays and five gallon jugs of wine and scotch. They needed to believe that such a life might be worth living. I didn't know that I'd be able to embrace such an unrewarding future, but I hoped that she could.
同样重要的是，他们需要一个计划。他们需要接受一个没有拥挤烟灰缸、五加仑红酒和苏格兰威士忌的全新且不同的未来的想法。他们需要相信这样的生活可能值得一过。我不知道自己是否能拥抱这样一个没有回报的未来，但我希望她能。
If she'd had it her way, we would've never known about the cancer. It was our father's idea to tell us, and she had fought it, agreeing only when he threatened to tell us himself. Our mother worried that once we found out, we would treat her differently, delicately. We might feel obliged to compliment her cooking and laugh at all of her jokes, thinking always of the tumor she was trying so hard to forget. And that is exactly what we did.
如果由她决定，我们永远不会知道她患了癌症。是父亲主张告诉我们的，她抗拒过，直到父亲威胁要亲自告诉我们，她才同意。母亲担心一旦我们知道了，对待她的态度会变，会变得小心翼翼。我们可能会觉得有义务夸奖她的厨艺，并对她所有的笑话发笑，心里总是想着她极力试图忘记的肿瘤。而这正是我们所做的。
The knowledge of her illness forced everything into the spotlight and demanded that it be memorable. We were no longer calling our mother. Now, we were picking up the telephone to call our mother with cancer. We realized that any conversation might be our last, and because of that, we wanted to say something important. But what could one say that hadn't already been printed on millions of greeting cards and helium balloons? "I love you," I said at the end of one of our late night phone calls. "I am going to pretend that I didn't hear that," she said. I heard a match strike in the background, the tinkling of ice cubes in a raised glass, and then she hung up.
对她病情的了解将一切都置于聚光灯下，并要求这一切必须令人难忘。我们不再是打电话给母亲。现在，我们拿起电话拨打给患癌的母亲。我们意识到任何对话都可能是最后一次，正因如此，我们想说些重要的。但有什么是数以百万计的贺卡和氦气球上没有印过的呢？“我爱你，”我们在一次深夜通话结束时说道。“我要假装没听到这句话，”她说。我听到背景中有火柴划过的声音，高脚杯中冰块的叮当声，然后她挂断了电话。
I had never said such a thing to my mother, and if I had it to do over again, I would probably take it back. It was queer to say such a thing to someone unless you were trying to talk them out of money or into bed. Our mother had taught us this when we were no taller than pony kegs. I had known people who said such things to their parents, "I love you." But it always translated to mean, "I'd love getting off the phone with you."
我从没对母亲说过这种话，如果能重来一次，我可能会收回。对一个人说这种话真怪，除非你是想骗他们的钱或者骗他们上床。母亲在我们还没小桶大时就教会了我们这一点。我认识对父母说过那种话的人，“我爱你。”但这总是翻译成，“我很想挂断你的电话。”
We gathered together for the wedding, which took place on a crisp, clear October afternoon. I took my mother's arm and led her to a bench beyond the range of the other guests. The thin mountain air made it difficult for her to breathe, and she moved slowly, pausing every few moments. The families had taken a walk to a nearby glen, and we sat in the shade, eating sausage biscuits and speaking to one another like well-mannered strangers.
我们聚在一起参加婚礼，婚礼是在一个清爽、晴朗的十月下午举行的。我挽着母亲的手，带她走到其他客人范围之外的长凳上。稀薄的山间空气让她呼吸困难，她走得很慢，每隔一会儿就停下来。家人们去附近的山谷散步，我们坐在树荫下，吃着香肠饼干，像彬彬有礼的陌生人一样交谈。
"The sausage is good," she said. "It's flavorful, but not too greasy." "Not too greasy at all. Still though, it isn't dry." "Neither are the biscuits," she said. "They're light and crisp, very buttery." "Very. These are some very buttery biscuits, They're flaky, but not too flaky. Not too flaky at all," she said. We watched the path, awkwardly waiting for someone to release us from the torture of our stiff and meaningless conversation.
“香肠不错，”她说。“味道浓郁，但不太油腻。”“一点也不油腻。不过，也不干。”“饼干也是，”她说。“它们轻盈酥脆，非常有黄油味。”“非常。这些是黄油味很重的饼干，它们薄片状，但又不会太碎。一点也不太碎，”她说。我们看着小路，尴尬地等待着有人能把我们从这呆板且毫无意义的对话折磨中解脱出来。
I'd always been afraid of sick people and so had my mother. I think it was their fortitude that frightened us. Sick people reminded us not of what we had, but of what we lacked. Everything we said sounded petty and insignificant. Our complaints paled in the face of theirs and without our complaints, there was nothing to say. My mother and I had been fine over the telephone, but now, face to face, the rules had changed.
我一直害怕病人，母亲也一样。我觉得是他们的坚毅吓到了我们。病人提醒我们的不是我们拥有什么，而是我们缺少什么。我们说的每一句话听起来都很琐碎且无关紧要。我们的抱怨在他们的面前显得苍白无力，没有了抱怨，也就无话可说。母亲和我在电话里还好，但现在面对面，规则变了。
If she were to complain, she risked being seen as a sick complainer, the worst kind of all. If I were to do it, I might come off sounding even more selfish than I actually was. This sudden turn of events had robbed us of our common language, leaving us to exchange the same innocuous pleasantries we'd always made fun of. I wanted to stop it, and so, I think, did she. But neither of us knew how.
如果她要抱怨，她就有被视为患病抱怨者的风险，这是最糟糕的一类。如果我抱怨，我可能会显得比实际更自私。这突如其来的转折剥夺了我们的共同语言，让我们只能交换那些我们一直嘲笑的陈词滥调。我想停止，我想她也想。但我们都不知道该怎么做。
After the gifts had been opened, we returned to our rooms at the Econo Lodge, the reservations having been made by my father. We looked out the windows, past the freeway and into the distance, squinting at the charming hotels huddled at the base of other, finer mountains. This would be the last time our family was all together.
礼物打开后，我们回到父亲预订的经济旅馆房间。我们看向窗外，越过高速公路，望向远处，眯着眼睛看着挤在其他更好山脚下的迷人酒店。这将是我们家最后一次聚在一起。
It's so rare when one knowingly does something for the last time, the last time you take a bath, the last time you have sex or trim your toenails. If you knew you'd never do it again, it might be nice to really make a show of it. This would be it as far as my family was concerned. And it ticked me off that our final meeting would take place in such a sorry excuse for a hotel.
一个人清醒地做某事做最后一次是多么罕见，最后一次洗澡，最后一次性爱或修剪脚趾甲。如果你知道你再也不会做了，真正把它演出来可能会很好。就我们家而言，这就是最后一次了。想到我们最后的见面竟然发生在这种寒酸的旅馆里，我就很生气。
"What more do you want out of a hotel?" he shouted, stepping out onto the patio in his underpants. "It's clean. They've got a couple of snack machines In the lobby. The TV's working. It's near the interstate. Who cares if you don't like the damn wallpaper. You know what your problem is, don't you?" "We're spoiled," we shouted in unison.
“你还想要酒店怎样？”他喊道，穿着短裤走上露台。“它很干净。大厅里有自动售货机。电视能用。它靠近州际公路。谁在乎你喜不喜欢这该死的墙纸。你知道你的问题是什么吗？”“我们被宠坏了，”我们异口同声地喊道。
My parents retired to their room, and the rest of us hiked to a nearby cemetery, a once ideal spot that now afforded an excellent view of the newly built Pizza Hut. Over the years, our mother had repeatedly voiced her desire to be cremated. We would drive past a small forest fire or observe the pillars of smoke rising from a neighbor's chimney, and she would crush her cigarette saying, "That's what I want right there. Do whatever you like with the remains. Sprinkle them into the ash trays of a fine hotel. Give them to smartass children for Christmas. Hand them over to the Catholics to rub into their foreheads. Just make sure I'm cremated."
父母回到他们的房间，其余的人徒步去附近的墓地，那是一个曾经理想的地方，现在却能极好地看到新盖的必胜客。多年来，母亲一再表示她希望火葬。我们会开车经过一场小型森林火灾，或者观察从邻居烟囱上升起的烟柱，她会掐灭香烟说，“那正是我想的那样。残骸随你怎么处理。撒进高级酒店的烟灰缸里。圣诞节送给那些自以为是的儿女。交给天主教徒涂在他们的前额上。只要确保我被火葬就行。”
"Oh Sharon," my father would groan, "you don't know what you want." He'd say it as though he himself had been cremated several times in the past, but had finally wised up and accepted burial as the only sensible option.
“噢，莎朗，”父亲会抱怨，“你根本不知道你要什么。”他说的好像他自己过去曾多次被火葬，但最终变聪明了，接受土葬作为唯一的明智选择。
We laid our Econo Lodge bedspreads over the dewy grass of the cemetery, smoking joints and trying to imagine a life without our mother. If there was a heaven, we probably shouldn't expect to find her there. Neither did she deserve to roam the fiery tar pits of hell, surrounded for all eternity by the same [BLEEP] heads who brought us strip malls and theme restaurants. There must exist some middle ground, a place where one was tortured on a daily basis but still allowed a few moments of pleasure taken wherever they could find it.
我们将经济旅馆的床罩铺在墓地带露水的草地上，抽着大麻，试图想象没有母亲的生活。如果真有天堂，我们可能不应该指望在那儿找到她。她也不值得在地狱里充满火焰的焦油坑中游荡，永生被那些给我们带来商业街和主题餐厅的[哔]头们包围。肯定存在某种中间地带，一个每天都受折磨，但仍然允许在任何能找到的地方获得一点点快乐的地方。
That place seemed to be Raleigh, North Carolina, so why the big fuss? Why couldn't she just stay where she was and not have cancer? Ever since arriving at the motor lodge, we'd gone back and forth from one room to another, holding secret meetings and exchanging private bits of information. We hoped that by preparing ourselves for the worst, we might be able to endure the inevitable with some degree of courage or grace.
那个地方似乎是北卡罗来纳州的罗利，那为什么大惊小怪呢？为什么她不能待在她待的地方，没有癌症呢？自从到达汽车旅馆以来，我们一直在两个房间之间走来走去，召开秘密会议，交换私密信息。我们希望通过为最坏的情况做好准备，我们也许能够带着某种程度的勇气或优雅忍受必然发生的事情。
Anything we forecasted was puny compared to the future that awaited us. You can't brace yourself for famine if you've never known hunger. It is foolish even to try. The most you can do is eat up while you still can, stuffing yourself, shovelling it in with both hands and licking clean the plates, recalling every course in vivid detail.
与等待我们的未来相比，我们预测的一切都微不足道。如果你从未经历过饥饿，你就无法为饥荒做好准备。即使尝试也是愚蠢的。你能做的最多就是在还能吃的时候吃个够，狼吞虎咽，用双手填满，舔净盘子，清晰地回忆每一道菜的细节。
Our mother was back in her room and very much alive, probably watching a detective program on television. Maybe that was her light in the window, her figure stepping out into the patio to light a cigarette. We told ourselves she probably wanted to be left alone. That's how stoned we were. We'd think of this later, each in our own separate way. I myself tend to dwell on the stupidity of pacing a cemetery while she sat, frightened and alone, staring at the tip of her cigarette and envisioning herself, clearly now, in ashes.
母亲回到了她的房间，活得好好的，可能正在看电视上的侦探节目。也许那是她窗户里的灯，是她走出露台点燃香烟的身影。我们告诉自己她可能想一个人待着。我们那时候多嗨啊。我们后来会想起这件事，每个人都以自己独特的方式。我自己倾向于沉思在墓地徘徊的愚蠢，而她却坐着，恐惧且孤独，盯着香烟头，清晰地想象着自己，灰烬。
David Sedaris's story, "Ashes," is from his book, Naked. His latest book is called Holidays On Ice. He was recorded by Time Warner Audio Books.
大卫·塞达里斯的《灰烬》摘自他的书《裸体》。他最新的一本书名为《假日冰上》。录音由时代华纳有声书制作。
Act Four, Ghost Story. Well, we figured we couldn't do a show about people who were haunted without at least one old-fashioned ghost story. This one is a very contemporary one. It's actually an excerpt from Heather Woodbury's amazing, eight hour, solo stage play, WhatEver. The play is this sprawling, epic story. Woodbury plays ten fully-developed characters and over 100 minor ones. We're just going to hear a tiny fragment of this thing here. Here is the set up.
第四幕，鬼故事。嗯，我们想如果不带上至少一个老式鬼故事，我们就没法做一期关于困扰人们的节目。这是一个非常现代的节目。它实际上是希瑟·伍德伯里令人惊叹的八小时独角戏《无论》（WhatEver）的片段。这出戏是一个宏大的史诗故事。伍德伯里扮演了十个成熟的角色和超过100个小角色。我们在这里只听到这个东西的一小部分。背景如下。
A character named Clove is at a rave party on a beach, goes out in the water, goes under, start to drown. People think it's a suicide. Then, somehow, she wakes up in a Brussels sprouts field. This is a few scenes later.
一个名叫克洛芙的角色在沙滩狂欢派对上，走进水里，潜入水下，开始溺水。人们以为那是自杀。然后，不知怎么的，她在抱子甘蓝田里醒了过来。这是几幕之后。
[DIAL TONE] [PHONE RINGING]
[拨号音] [电话铃响]
Hannah, could you put Sable on the phone? Hannah, Sable. Your big sister Sable. Give me Sable. Children, egg me to such excess at times. Sable? Yeah, it's Clove. Hi, yeah, yeah. No, I'm all right. Are you in trouble? Ugh, I'm sorry. What's that humming sound on the line? Oh, your parents are chanting. I'm so relieved my parents aren't Buddhists. Are they all agged and stuff about me drowning at the rave and getting arrested and like that?
汉娜，你能让塞布尔接电话吗？汉娜，塞布尔。你的大姐姐塞布尔。把塞布尔给我。孩子们，有时真让我极度恼火。塞布尔？是的，我是克洛芙。嗨，是的，是的。不，我没事。你遇到麻烦了吗？呃，抱歉。线路上那个嗡嗡声是什么？哦，你父母在诵经。我真庆幸我父母不是佛教徒。他们对我在狂欢节溺水和被捕之类的事感到极度愤怒吗？
Your parents are so overly righteous or something at times. I'm not sure. It doesn't matter. Forget it. It's too dull. Never mind.
你父母有时真是太自以为是了。我不确定。没关系。忘了它。太无聊了。没关系。
Anyway, no my parents are calm. They were all indignant that I talked to the state troopers and didn't go all silent and recite my rights and stuff. But they didn't get hectic about, "Don't take drugs like we did. LSD almost ruined our marriage." Blah blah blah. Yeah, they were non-typically all quiet. I think my mom is spazzed that I'm a teen suicide risk or something.
总之，不，我父母很冷静。他们对我和州警交谈而没有保持沉默并宣读我的权利之类的事情感到愤慨。但他们并没有大惊小怪地叫嚷，“别像我们一样吸毒。LSD差点毁了我们的婚姻。”之类的。是的，他们一反常态地安静。我想我妈妈是被吓坏了，因为我是青少年自杀高危人群之类的。
No, Sable, is this you? No, I was just being all excessive in the water under the moonlight. It's like the moon was making this crescent cookie shape, cutting cookies in the back of my head even though I was looking the other way. And the crabs were talking to me. It doesn't matter. Never mind, it's too complex. I can't.
不，塞布尔，是你吗？不，我只是在月光下的水中表现得太极端了。感觉月亮做成了这个新月饼干的形状，在我后脑勺切饼干，即使我看向相反的方向。螃蟹在跟我说话。没关系。没关系，太复杂了。我不能。
Well, yeah, yeah, I was with that dude, Skitter. No? Oh yeah, Skeeter. Well, yeah. We were by the cave by that dead sea lion or walrus, whatever. Do you think he's flaccid and weak, or do you think he's rad? Right on. I'm so relieved. Yeah, well we got slithery. Yeah, that's when I went to the waves, to wash his protein shake off my hand. My hand. Sable, I didn't like him that much.
好吧，是的，是的，我和那个家伙斯基特在一起。不？哦，是的，斯基特。嗯，是的。我们在那个死海狮或海象旁边的洞穴里，不管那是什么。你觉得他软弱无力，还是你觉得他很酷？太棒了。我真庆幸。是的，好吧，我们变得滑溜溜的。是的，就在那时我走到波浪边，洗掉手上的蛋白质奶昔。我的手。塞布尔，我不怎么喜欢他。
So do you really want to hear what happened? You promise you won't think I'm all Juliette Lewis? All right, I go to the waves, and the ocean started talking or singing to me. It's like the ocean was this green spreading gown and it was pulling me in it. And then these crabs were biting my toes. That's how they communicate. Yeah, they were telling me all these rad things. Oh yeah, you should see my toes. They are retchedly butchered. It's gruesome to excess.
所以你真的想听发生了什么吗？你保证不会觉得我像朱丽叶特·刘易斯？好吧，我走到波浪边，大海开始对我说话或唱歌。就像大海是一件绿色的长袍，把我卷了进去。然后这些螃蟹在咬我的脚趾。那就是它们交流的方式。是的，它们在告诉我所有这些激进的事情。哦，是的，你应该看看我的脚趾。它们被残忍地蹂躏了。非常血腥，极其残忍。
But anyway, the crabs were pulling my toes and teaching me how to dance this crazy turning pattern for the moon. And then I could live under the waves and give the ocean something back for us destroying it, like me for the sea lion, a life for a life. I know. I thought you said you-- yeah. Isn't it raging? Yeah.
但总之，螃蟹在拉我的脚趾，教我如何为月亮跳这种疯狂的旋转舞。然后我可以生活在波浪下，为我们摧毁它而还给大海一点东西，像我为海狮做的那样，一命抵一命。我知道。我以为你说你——是的。不是很狂野吗？是的。
So I guess I was far out on the rocks. And the waves were slashing all about me. And I see this seahorse man crashing and raging way out in the middle of it. And I-- Sable, girl dude, he was excessively real. Do you believe me? Rad. And then Skitter, oh yeah, I mean Skeeter, was calling to me. And I don't know what I answered, but I jumped in.
所以我猜我当时在遥远的岩石上。波浪在我周围汹涌澎湃。我看到这个海马人在中间翻腾狂怒。然后我——塞布尔，女孩伙计，他极其真实。你相信我吗？太棒了。然后斯基特，哦，是的，我是说斯基特，在呼唤我。我不知道我回答了什么，但我跳了进去。
And the next thing I knew, I was swirling around in the waves, and then I see this white, white dude. And he's pushing the seahorse man back under the waves, and he's pulling back the dress of the waves to keep it from going over my neck. And then he floats across the ocean to me, and he says, "This is way [BLEEP]."
接下来的事我知道了，我在波浪中旋转，然后我看到了这个白，白人家伙。他把海马人推回波浪下，他把波浪的长裙拉开以防它盖过我的脖子。然后他浮过大海来到我身边，说，“这太[哔]了。”
And he leads me down underwater over these underwater mountains into this underwater valley where there's this underwater farm. But it turned out later-- the state troopers told me-- that I had gotten in this cave and crawled over these rocks up a cliff and across the road to the Brussels sprouts farm where they arrested me.
他带我潜入水下，翻过这些水下山脉进入这个水下山谷，那里有一个水下农场。但后来——州警告诉我的——我钻进了这个洞穴，爬过这些岩石，翻过悬崖，穿过马路来到他们逮捕我的抱子甘蓝农场。
So this way pale dude leaves me there. And Sable, this is fiendishly odd. Don't spazz. He goes-- he's all, "Don't tell people you saw me." And I'm all, "Who are you anyway?" Sable, promise not to tell anyone. Thou, right on. He's all, "I'm Cobain the friendly ghost." I'm being excessively real. This was totally realistic. I was all, whoa, Kurt. I know. I know. We don't even like Nirvana. Well, In Utero is a good album. It is. Never mind. No, I mean never mind, not Nevermind. Anyway, never mind. Yeah, isn't it raging?
所以这个苍白的家伙把我留在那里。塞布尔，这真是诡异得离谱。别发疯。他走——他一直说，“别告诉别人你见过我。”我一直说，“你到底是谁？”塞布尔，发誓别告诉任何人。好，太棒了。他说，“我是友好鬼魂柯本。”我表现得极其真实。这完全是真实的。我一直说，哇，库尔特。我知道。我知道。我们甚至不喜欢涅槃乐队。嗯，《子宫内》（In Utero）是一张好专辑。确实是。没关系。不，我是说没关系，不是《别介意》（Nevermind）。总之，没关系。是的，不是很狂野吗？
[SNORING SOUNDS]
[打鼾声]
Who's that? What in the devil? Who's there? What is it? Eliot? Is that you? You frightened me. No, it's not Eliot, is it? But you are a ghost, aren't you? I thought you might been my last husband, dear. Who are you? Coltrane? Coltrane the friendly ghost? Well, I'm awfully glad you're friendly dear, but you don't look a thing like Mr. Coltrane. I saw him play many, many times you know. And I'd say you're awfully pale, even for a ghost, if you're John Coltrane. What is it  dear? What's that? Co-bin? Co-bin? Kurt Co-bin? Who knows.
那是谁？到底怎么回事？谁在那儿？是什么？埃利奥特？是你吗？你吓坏我了。不，不是埃利奥特，是吗？但你是个鬼魂，对吗？我以为你可能是我最后一任丈夫，亲爱的。你是谁？科尔特兰？友好鬼魂科尔特兰？好吧，我很高兴你是友好的亲爱的，但你看起来一点也不像科尔特兰先生。你知道我见过他演奏很多很多次。如果你是约翰·科尔特兰，即使对于鬼魂来说，我也觉得你太苍白了。是什么亲爱的？那是什么？科宾？科宾？库尔特·科宾？谁知道呢。
Well, Kurt Cobain wanders around haunting various characters throughout Heather Woodbury's WhatEver. The eight-hour version will be touring the United States in 1998. Her director, Dudley Saunders, has also produced an eight-hour radio play of the epic solo show from which this was excerpted.
嗯，库尔特·科宾在希瑟·伍德伯里的《无论》中游荡并困扰着各种角色。八小时版本将于1998年在全美巡演。她的导演达德利·桑德斯也制作了一部八小时的广播剧，摘自这部史诗般的独角戏。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder. Senior editor Paul Tough. Contributing editors Jack Hit, Margie Rockland and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Alex Blumberg and Rachel Howard.
嗯，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我本人制作，艾利克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德参与。高级编辑保罗·塔夫。特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克兰和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。亚历克斯·布隆伯格和瑞秋·霍华德提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买本节目的录音带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ，312-832-3380。312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址，[email protected]。本《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who says every week after our show--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他每周节目结束后都会说——
One's enough for me baby. I'll never go through it again.
宝贝，对我来说一个就够了。我再也不会经历那一切了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共电台，PRI。